[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez tous reconnu Barack Obama
en novembre 2008 il a été élu 44e
président des États-Unis d'Amérique
en janvier 2009
il est le premier président
afro-américain
de ce pays
Marie Corée série
ce nom reste gravé dans l'histoire de la
Côte d'Ivoire
en février 1950
elle sort de prison
elle avait été arrêtée avec d'autres
femmes à la suite de la marche sur
Grand-Bassam pour libérer les
prisonniers politiques dans leurs époux
et enfants aujourd'hui elle est un
symbole de la résistance féminine
ivoirienne
et l'ancien billet de 1000 francs Cfa
était estampillés à son effigie
Clémentine gauli
en 2013 elle devient la première femme
conductrice de poids lourds dans la
région du bass à Sandra un rêve
qu'elle a nourri pendant plusieurs
années
et depuis lors elle est toujours la
seule femme parmi 1500 ans
qu'est-ce que toutes ces personnes ont
en commun
avec confiance
elles ont affronté les difficultés
elles ont gravi des montagnes et elles
ont réalisé leur rêve
ce soir
je voudrais vous faire partager
au travers de quelques expériences de ma
vie
comment j'ai gravi des montagnes
et pour moi cela se résume en trois mots
se connaître
s'adapter
et osé
se connaître c'est très important
parce qu'on se connaissant on découvre
les compétences que nous avons on
apprend à reconnaître ses limites on
apprend à planifier mettre en place des
stratégies pour combler ses lacunes
on me pose souvent la question de savoir
comment est-ce que tu es arrivé dans la
communication
pour ceux qui ne le savent pas je suis
ingénieur agronome diplômé de l'Institut
national polytechnique de Côte d'Ivoire
je suis un pur produit de l'école
ivoirienne
tout commence dans les années 2000
lorsqu'un stage met offert dans une
entreprise
mais il ne s'agit pas d'un stage
technique
je dois développer un business plan
mettre en place une stratégie marketing
pour le lancement d'une nouvelle gamme
de produits
après discussion avec le directeur
marketing il me demande
mademoiselle bissouma mon nom de jeune
fille
êtes-vous sûr que vous pouvez le faire
bien sûr je peux le faire quelqu'un qui
n'a jamais fait d'études marketing et
qui n'a pas fait d'école de commerce
je me mets tout de suite
à bosser bouquiner pour ceux qui ont
fait le marketing vous connaissez la
bible du marketing qu'on appelle le
conteneur et du bois
des centaines de pages nuits tes jours
pendant 6 mois
je finis mon rapport
et je dois le présenter mais ce que je
ne savais pas surprise
le directeur marketing du groupe devait
être présent
allons-y
je présente mon rapport
quelques semaines plus tard je suis
appelé par le PDG de l'entreprise
on m'offre un emploi permanent de
Marketing Manager
c'est comme ça que je commence à flirter
avec le marketing et la communication au
fil des années j'apprends les offres
consommateurs les plans marketing les
stratégies commerciales
après presque 10 ans je me dis je dois
me réorienter en fait
agronome avec les tennis et les bottes
peut-être que ça ne s'y est pas trop
mais pour ce faire il faut que je me
prépare il faut que je sache ce que je
veux devenir demain
je me connais
je suis très battante quand je veux
quelque chose
je l'obtiens
allons par le bien de Nami avec qui j'ai
fait le Master Management à Abidjan il
me permet de rencontrer une charmante
dame pour la première fois j'ai un coach
professionnel
nous discutons et ensemble nous
convenons que ma prochaine carrière
c'est dans le marketing et la
communication mais comment y arriver
je me connais
je connais mes lacunes
je sais que pour la communication il
faut avoir un niveau d'anglais bien
élevé je prends des cours d'anglais
tous les jours j'en professeur privé
mais ce qui est important quand on a un
rêve c'est de pouvoir matérialiser ce
rêve je me voyais déjà en tant que
directrice de la communication d'une
grande boîte j'avais changé mon style
vestimentaire je ne partais plus au
bureau en jean je portais des tailleurs
j'ai changé les les tennis avec les
escarpins à tel point qu'un jour ma
patronne me dit waouh Peggy
tu es toute classe elle ne savait pas
que j'allais la quitter
quant avec ma coach on décide que nous
sommes prêts
prochaine étape où vas-tu aller
alors je lui dis tu sais
j'ai toujours rêvé de travailler dans
une compagnie
le lait les oiseaux
depuis que je suis petit en plus je rêve
d'aller en Suisse mais ça c'est pour
plus tard
alors j'envoie une candidature spontanée
dans cette boîte j'envoie un email une
lettre de motivation
je n'ai rien à perdre le seul risque
c'est qu'il ne me répondent pas
et vous savez ce qu'il s'est passé
ils ne m'ont pas répondu
les semaines passent j'ai le cœur qui
bat mais quand on est prêt on sait être
patient
quelques mois plus tard je suis
contactée par le directeur des
ressources humaines de cette entreprise
madame Dibi vous avez un entretien
je passe les entretiens parmi plusieurs
candidates et candidats je suis retenu
responsable communication pour les SLI
Côte d'Ivoire
[Applaudissements]
quand on se connaît
on se prépare pour s'adapter
c'est la deuxième étape
s'adapter ça veut dire
pouvoir survivre dans un environnement
incertain et lorsqu'on arrive à
maîtriser cet environnement on excelle
je fais ma carrière après trois années
on me propose un poste à l'étranger
première expatriation
quand on dit expatriation générale vous
pensez
avantage maison payer
étude des enfants pris en charge mais
très peu de personnes se rendent compte
des difficultés de l'expatriation
je pars de la Côte d'Ivoire avec un
enfant de 11 mois
deux filles âgées de 6 ans et 12 ans à
l'époque
un mari qui travaille comment on va
faire peut-être qu'il va rester ici ou
bien il va partir on essaie de trouver
les arrangements première destination
Accra on arrive au Ghana c'est juste à
côté vous me direz que c'est dans la
sous région mais c'est un pays
anglophone
je dois changer ma langue de travail je
ne parle plus le français maintenant
c'est l'anglais je dois vivre avec les
enfants dans les conditions assez
agréables et vous savez des faux Ghana
les coupures d'électricité il y a pas
d'eau on a vécu ça on a dû s'adapter
trois ans plus tard quatre ans plus tard
j'ai une proposition en 2017 pour aller
en Suisse le pays de mes rêves
j'y ai rêvé mais encore une fois je
devais m'adapter
imaginez quitter son confort ici en Côte
d'Ivoire où on a la nounou le chauffeur
la femme de ménage je me retrouve en
Suisse avec trois enfants sans aide à
domicile
un mari qui travaille mais qui doit
voyager régulièrement donc il y a des
périodes où je suis seul j'ai dû
m'adapter mais pas seul mes enfants ont
dû s'adapter parce qu'ils ont abandonné
leurs amis ils ont changé
d'environnement de travail
mais ce qui m'a forgé dans ma capacité
d'adaptation ce sont les encouragements
que j'ai reçu j'ai rencontré des mains
torts j'ai rencontré des collègues qui
m'ont aidé mais au-dessus de tout
mais supporters éternels ma famille ils
étaient toujours là j'ai dû m'adapter on
a changé les repas dominicaux de
dimanche avec des appels téléphoniques
tous les soirs pour ne pas sentir la
solitude nous avons dû nous adapter
17 heures c'est 17h vous connaissez les
horloges suisses je me rappelle qu'une
fois
j'ai été invitée à manger j'ai des amis
suisses bien sûr
19h heure africaine non j'arrive à 19h45
ils étaient déjà presque après l'entrée
je dis je suis désolé
la fois d'après quand j'organise un
repas chez moi j'étais plus qu'à l'heure
parce qu'il fallait que les invités
soient vraiment au rendez-vous
quand on arrive à s'adapter on sort de
sa zone de confort
et quand on sort de sa zone de confort
on peut s'ouvrir des opportunités et on
arrive à oser
l'an dernier j'ai osé vaincre ma peur
j'ai peur du vide j'ai toujours eu peur
de vide
j'arrive en Suisse en 2017
et je vois dans le ciel toujours un
balai de voile coloré je dis waouh un
jour je ferai de la parapente mais
pendant 5 ans tous les samedis matin je
disais un jour je vais faire de la
parapente
jusqu'au jour où je reçois un bon cadeau
de mes collègues peut-être une amie le
leur a dit expérience en parapente je
dis ok là je vais voler
mais je ne veux pas voler seul qui est
fou
je demande à une copine on y va ensemble
tu veux m'accompagner waouh génial donc
nous décidons de faire ce vol en
parapente ensemble
on prend le rendez-vous samedi on y va
mais je vous assure que la veille je
n'ai pas dormi
toutes les questions venaient dans ma
tête ici il y a pas de vent
et si la voile se déchire
mais est-ce que je vais pas tomber et
puis après je dis non je dois le faire
pour prouver à mes enfants que leur mère
est forte le lendemain nous arrivons au
lieu de rencontre
et quand on dit vol en parapente il faut
partir de la hauteur
on prend un mini van
vous voyez sur ces photos il y a des
montagnes mais il y a des chemins dans
ces montagnes la largeur de la route
c'est la largeur d'une voiture mais
c'est une voie à deux sens à certains
endroits il n'y a même pas de garde-fou
et la vitesse vous savez les Suisses
respecte la vitesse limitation de
vitesse 80 km heure imaginez ce n'est
pas très
très long c'est rapide et nous étions
assise au devant du van et au fur et à
mesure que la voiture montait dans ces
ruelles serpentés des montagnes j'avais
peur je me demandais mais est-ce que ce
n'est pas une bêtise
j'ai récité toutes les prières que ma
mère m'a apprise je te promets maman
j'ai récité toutes les prières
on arrive au sommet de la montagne 1400
mètres de haut
la vue était magnifique mais il faut
descendre quand tu es au sommet il faut
descendre je demande au moniteur parce
que ce sont des vols en biplace donc il
y a celui qui fait le vol et le moniteur
comme on fait maintenant il dit
t'inquiète pas tu te mets juste au bord
de la falaise et puis tu te laisses
aller
ok avec réticence je m'avance au bord de
la falaise mais ce qu'il a dit c'est
vrai parce que c'est pas un parachute en
parachute on saute en parapente on vole
dès que le vent soulève la voile je
ferme les yeux la vue est magnifique
vous tous vous voulez aller au sommet je
vous encourage la vue est magnifique au
sommet
mais pour aller au sommet il faut gravir
les montagnes
il faut s'armer de courage il faut se
préparer
lorsque je suis descendu à
l'atterrissage le vol ne fait que 20 30
minutes pas plus j'ai dit yes je vais le
refaire et je le referai encore cette
année
alors ce soir
à travers mes petites expériences
je voudrais dire à tous ceux qui ont des
rêves
rêver c'est beau
mais un il faut se connaître apprenez à
vous connaître apprenez à vous préparer
apprenez à vous découvrir
soyez prêt à vous adapter
il y aura des vents il y aura des
montagnes les chemins seront tortueux
mais il faudra oser faire le pas
le sommet est magnifique mais pour
gravir la montagne il faut vraiment être
prêt je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]